i think i'm gonna you know what i think
you just changed me wow i think i'm just
gonna be that be that bobby you're the
kindest person i know what's up
did you meet
nora aquafina how are you
hi it's my niece oh so that's just a
podcast with bobby no idea what's going
on nice let me ask you is that what
you're going to wear to do jeremiah's
podcast
in pajamas all right all right cool just
coming up come on in come on you come in
for a second i need to talk to you about
something
stand in the middle of the [ __ ] room
she's doing a podcast yeah yeah
number one i've been gone for three
weeks when i saw you today
i know but you i i know but i want a hug
yeah but you didn't greet her happy
birthday oh
oh my god wow i don't know
so happy birthday thank you thank you
i'll see you three weeks okay see that's
why
give her the keys give her the keys
i don't have them you better stand in
the middle oh they're right here do you
want these
one last thing though one last thing one
last thing you have you been using the
car yeah all right
sorry no when i went into the car
earlier right
what did the thing say
one
oh it wasn't her it wasn't her i can
actually tell you it wasn't her you no
it was marianne
she took the car for three days and
didn't fill it back up wait wait wait
[ __ ] face mary ann took my car for three
days yeah she took her daughter to
disneyland though be nice oh disneyland
oh no oh my god
all right
one last thing one last thing one last
thing right you represent the family
you kill it on the podcast
it's a franchise baby she's gonna kill
it
all right you're gonna kill it don't
make me look like a fool by jewel drive
safe that's hilarious
that's what i'm talking about i wasn't
gentle there no you weren't i went
against my nature yeah but you love her
so deeply yeah so you you read gas
from like one what does one mean
one bar
of gas
one bar of gas of gold no gas of gas so
it's like
it's like the equivalent of like one bar
of like a phone yes yes yes that's not
equivalent no i i disagree no don't have
to do not do that
just because you know that's exactly
like it is like don't do that you're
wrong you're absolutely wrong
no there's six bars
okay okay right eight bars how many
miles is one bar
here's the deal dude
my brother and i
five years ago rented a car a lincoln
okay
we were driving you know los angeles
because you live in l.a now last year
you know when you go to la cienega
boulevard and it turns in the sunset
yeah you know exactly where that yeah
how steep is los angeles it's pretty
steep huh
[ __ ] steep as [ __ ] would you say
right yes yes okay so one day on a
friday five o'clock
i was going up that [ __ ] road it was
raining
and friday clock at five o'clock in that
road is the worst traffic on planet
earth yeah and i ran out of gas there
while it was raining oh my god imagine
what i call it stevie with stevie
right
him and i had gasoline all over her body
because we didn't know how to open the
[ __ ] thing so when we would pour it
in the car it would go on oh my god
oh my god and people were like [ __ ] you
like driving by going
[ __ ] you i don't wanna outsider on it
you know what i mean
so a doorman named steven fury drove by
he's no longer a doorman he's a
legitimate he's a legitimate comedian
but back then he was i feel like i made
him
so throw that out there but um he made
you from this experience
so
yeah
so he's like
i'm steve and i'm a doorman i'll go get
so he went and got gas he did it for us
we drove away and he opened for me
wow yeah but my point is ever since then
even if it's a bar nora
i get scared that i'm gonna get run out
i'm gonna run out of gas don't you don't
get scared
um
i've been so poor that i've been on
e empty so much that i know exactly
oh yeah because
like i put exactly five dollars in just
to get to class
so i'm always hovering on e so i know
exactly how many miles i have on my old
camry there's always a dude that's like
nah after that it's 25 miles you're good
25 those are almost 25 mile guys yes
i feel like that's true because they
can't they're not going to leave us like
that yeah they can't leave us like that
actually on a prius you have at least
like 60 miles oh that's like a hundred
thousand miles yeah after you i don't
know that i've been telling you for
eight i don't like it i just don't like
it
i don't like the fear
right yeah leave me two three two three
bars
the worst is when you're like i don't i
mean if you've been to new york like the
i-87 and you're driving like in the
middle of the night
between like 30 mile exits and you don't
know when you can get gas next that's
when it hits oh
that's probably the worst yeah and then
you go on your google maps or whatever
right and then you you can it's so far
away from where you are yeah
yeah
i can't do that i feel the anxiety too
yeah yeah yeah does your car make a
noise or
i have yes yes it does what do you have
a what
no i it does make a noise it's an
electric car probably doesn't need gas
i know
who is a tesla it's that people have a
tesla yeah people have teslas i have
friends have teslas yeah
i thought you were talking about a tesla
earlier i did it wasn't i can't afford
it but um
for the special people
what does tesla do i didn't roll up here
to tesla no i don't have it you have
more than one car yes you're five cars
no no
so what's doing well that's all no let
me ask you this nor i i don't know i
mean
because you know
we've seen each other last couple years
yeah but your life has changed
dramatically
would you say or no
i mean
since we last talked since a lot i mean
no since the last time you did tiger
belly to now right you would you